[Music]
lastly no clue here comes the booth all
dressed and boo Leslie Knope boo boo
dude what are you doing I'm being
awesome boo boo Leslie be my friend I
don't think you understand what a bad
idea this is I don't think you
understand that I would have got a cut
of that new paunch burger if she hadn't
screwed everything up so sorry guys this
wedding is canceled because the bride is
a bee hole hey check this out
Steve stick bori choking oh my god
where'd you even get a stink bomb Amazon
baby that song you are looking at a
Prime customer everybody two days free
shipping for this guy let's get this
party started with another one gang oh
it's cerebral Jerri you do the wedding
who cares
come on man just go home now who's gonna
make me it's your wedding day I'll
handle this here comes the bride time to
go sir
No the hell man she touched me I'll give
you that one but if you do it again if I
do one again what kick your ass how you
like you want me to do the halter yo I
looked at the photos of your victim on
your desk
it's that Bertha Jo I said hi puncture
wounds are similar to a case I had a
while back they aren't from a knife I
think it's something spiral like a
corkscrew don't shush me I'm helping you
baby that was actually very helpful
thank you oh you better get back here
now
oh hello Peralta no now why yourself set
man I'm the one who had to come to this
backwater stink hole what's up little
man what's up you feeling sexy huh yeah
I feel sexy and you look sexy you know I
do stuff for that door yo how much you
bench seriously captain please please
pretty please do not let him take over
my case major crimes is stepping in
nothing I can do
you're off the case I can't believe
you're just rolling over and give it my
murder away to the vulture we call him
the vulture because he swoops in and
solves cases that almost solvent takes
the credit for himself yes boil up put
that together from context first of all
major crimes has jurisdiction over any
in all cases they want to take but more
importantly you're the one who insisted
on working alone I told you for weeks to
use the squad and you refused I used
them I mean Rosa's the one who figured
out the corkscrew and Charles caught a
dog well congratulations detective Boyle
you should have involved them sooner
turn over your files to detective
Pembroke sir Coleman sir giving him a
name makes him human turn over the files
fine but in protest I'm walking over
there extremely slowly thank you
god it's so boring for both of us you
know before I saw this case I'd like to
thank you for doing all this super-easy
work you know the real Nancy Drew level
stuff oh yeah did Nancy Drew solve a lot
of murders yeah she did murder a nice
recipe for murder and so was a wonderful
detective I wanted to be her when I grew
up thanks Charles that's helpful
hey should we take odds on how fast I'll
solve this case
no I mean what was it with Diaz's last
impossible extortion case was it six
hours that's because it was 98% solved
the last 2% ours to get that's why they
leave it in the milk what oh wow
looking good Santiago yeah foxy ma go
rot in hell this is your fault
thanks Jim good effort I got it from
here hey you feel free to call me
anytime you need me to come down here
and help powder that big white ass of
yours hmm well that's the worst thing
that's ever happened to me I sit here
you know I I know a little bit about
what you're going through in a way that
was a kid my parents got divorced they
both want to custody and they both asked
me to testify against the other one in
court so I don't know I didn't want to
get divorced in the first place I love
them both so much okay so let's get
ready for the photo guys I want you to
arrange yourselves from most excited
about democracy to least excited wait a
minute everybody's excited I bet you are
because your bill just became law well
you know I can't believe you traded your
office to keep this craphole pool open
for a couple more weeks a year
hey you don't say that in front of the
kids please I'm trying to teach them how
great government is oh this is a
teaching moment
great hey kids would you like to learn
how Leslie got your bill passed
Councilwoman Knope traded my vote for
her what the hell man why'd you do that
[Applause]
captain I don't know if this is too much
but I got deputy chief Brandt this
little basket of pears they look right
and crispy hello Raymond captain wuntch
good to see you but if you're here who's
guarding Hades it's deputy chief wuntch
now unsurprisingly I've been promoted
above you and now I'm here to evaluate
you what happened a brand he retired and
moved to Charleston to be closer to his
grandchildren so much for dying at your
desk with a little dignity interesting I
will attempt to cooperate with you under
these new circumstances don't sweet-talk
me halt
I gave it my best shot let's begin Kelly
how are you I heard that the longest me
Oh welcome to my convenience store would
you like some cookie Kobe I have some
very delicious cookie cookie only 99
cents plus tax
try my Googie Googie my cookie go try my
cookie-cookie
time
all right all right yes that was great
she gets it now she knows what it's like
to be a minority you know that my dream
has always been having a picture taken
with a mountain of recovered cash that's
always been my dream to take that
picture of you Jake yeah
twenty-one million dollars Raymond I
have to admit I'm impressed
oh sorry to disappoint you Madeline I
know you'd hope we failed oh no I
couldn't be happier wait why would you
say that and why aren't you clenching
your little red hands in anger
didn't want me to fail you wanted me to
succeed that's right
I was looking for an excuse to promote
you to a desk job and you handed it to
me on a silver platter with your little
rat hands Oh No say goodbye to the
nine-nine Raymond I'm making you head of
NYPD public relations captain get in
here with me
go ahead smile for the cameras Raymond
that's your new job now next order of
business its agenda item 280 be a motion
to construct a dog park on municipal lot
48 MS Ludgate you have the floor Thank
You councilman Jamm your help and
general non awfulness is much
appreciated Leslie members of the
council I believe that municipal lot 48
should be a dog park I boo well it
sounds like there's considerable
opposition of this so I'm sorry miss
legate you should go now really I just
heard one hag booing ladies please let's
keep this civil councilman pawneeans
satisfied customers of jamm orthodontics
as we discuss what type of park to put
on lot 48 I had thought how about no
park who here thinks parks are stupid
let the record show that everyone is
raising their hands I happen to know for
a fact that pawnees favorite fast food
restaurant paunch burger needs a new
location now seeing as how the future of
lot 48 is open for debate I am
we sell it to paunch burger for a nice
profit you don't even have to be Asian
to do math that simple you told me you
wanted a dog park psychic
it's not fair you lied to me you just
got jammed
you